okay what up guys welcome to the just
pearly things youtube channel and
welcome to the pre-game
before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification bell the way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos as you
guys know if you have watched three or
more of my lives and you don't subscribe
we have beef okay that is not cool
um a subscription like subscribing is
free you don't even have to pay to
subscribe so do that it's free while
you're at it all super chats during the
stream will be read so if you guys want
if you have a question for the panel and
you want us to read it send a super chat
and i will
on top of that our
show sponsors cooking with chris so
cooking with chris offers completely
customizable meal plans so what you do
is you go to him you tell him what you
like to eat already and he makes you a
custom-made meal plan for you i'm down
12 pounds on this diet okay
[Music]
why are you so why do you sound
surprised when i said that last year
like
it's like a good like
12 pounds
thank you thank you
okay and then also turn on notifications
because every wednesday thursday and
saturday i do this live show 9 p.m 9 30
not nine
um so yeah subscribe okay
so to start the show i know you guys
have seen a lot of these faces before
but go around say your name your age
your relationship status
and
where you are from
all right i'll go first um my name is
jessica i am from southern california
and i am 27 years old my relation status
is single
i'm amani i'm 22 years old um
i'm in a relationship a six-year
relationship and i'm from south london
i'm sam i'm 25 i am still single
i'm from south of england
okay so the topic for today
is is hookup culture conducive for
relationships like now that we have
birth control in society now hookup
culture
is rampant
do you think it's better for
relationships um say yes or no and why
when you say better for relationships
like like you're in a relationship you
can
hook up with
no i just mean like like they used to
court each other in the old days and now
it's like like it's hook ever we kind of
sleep our way into relationships
i don't think it's good
personally
um as to why i feel like
um just speaking from personal
experience i feel like you
you can get you can think you like
somebody and then end up hooking up with
them and then you're like oh my gosh i
like them but then once you guys don't
do anything for a few weeks you're like
i actually don't like you i like what we
can do together but i don't like you on
top of that yeah yeah i think no what do
you think um
i agree with jess i feel like
maybe
i feel like if it's the pathway to a
relationship
um
you might be you might think that a
person is someone that not and then
eventually like you guys start to talk
and stuff like that if the first thing
you do is like sex and then after like
you're attracted to them sexually but
then you realize mentally you guys are
not on the same page so i didn't like no
i don't think
what do you think exactly the same like
if you're hooking up it's all just a
physical attraction physical connection
but then
there's nothing emotional there and
three months down the line it's just
gonna break
it's interesting was that your take last
show cause i feel like you had a
different take last show no
i've been single a few months now
[Laughter]
okay fair enough um so question as a guy
do you take a girl more seriously if she
makes you wait
[Laughter]
um
[Music]
yeah i'd say it probably means she maybe
has a bit more respect for herself okay
yeah
dang
so you're saying the ones that
don't wait have less respect
[Laughter]
do you disagree no it's just
i disagree do you disagree like i feel
like if some girls can like sex as much
as guys can like sex
it's not about respect or not respect
you know i mean
does that make sense it doesn't make
sense like we both like sex
i just think girls are accurate risk so
like if a girl sleeps around like if she
gets an std it affects her like it
doesn't really if a guy is the same so i
think like when i think of respect for
yourself like i think of
like i don't know they think their body
is like special not everyone can get it
but
you don't think if a girl slept sleeps
with a hundred guys
that like
because
that lowers her respect for herself
you know what i don't know i feel like
in gen like that's a lot so i don't know
if they i don't know
like 100 is a lot to go off
well the reason i go to the extreme is
just to show like
you have to go to ex to the extreme to
show that like it's a thing
because if you say zero if you if i went
to the other extreme and said do you
think a girl has a lot of respect for
herself would she slept with zero people
what would your immediate answer be
yeah yeah
what i'm saying what i'm
saying is like i'm not really talking
about the extremes because there's
sometimes like girls okay maybe it's a
girl that probably just came out of a
relationship right
and um
like she's met someone she's like she's
not after a relationship after a breakup
you know sometimes you make mistakes
right and then she just um
sleeps around not sleeps around but
maybe she meets someone right and then
she sleeps with him straight away yeah
does that mean she doesn't have respect
for herself like that's probably her the
second time she's had sex with someone
and if we're saying she doesn't have
respect for herself when she was she
could have not been in the right space
of mine is that is that fair
um
do i think that's fair sort of yeah
i mean i don't think like she has to
have zero respect like that means she
has no respect for herself ever i just
think it means like that action like you
can't you know in that moment she did it
as well yeah do you is that what you
found like with your friends and like
in situations because i know you've been
in a relationship forever but you
probably get the ear in on like all your
single friends yeah
so um with that would you say that most
girls regret like one night stands and
like hookups
it all depends on the person yes the
person who you're talking to like i was
saying earlier
there's a
i have a group of friends back home and
they were um
they were talking about like i'm done
with men there's that in the third this
summer we're for the streets and i'm
like
huh
and so i think it all depends on who it
is there could be people who don't care
who they sleep with
they could sleep with somebody that they
don't really
find attraction but they can scratch
that itch that they have and they just
go on with their day and so i think it
comes down to the person and
if they
really think about like do i really
respect myself in this situation or hey
it's my body i can do what i want
so
ladies okay this is gonna be a tougher
one for you because when did you start
dating your boyfriend 15 okay
i guess you can't really
i guess you can't really answer this
question but
have you found that
you make guys wait longer if you see
them as relationship material
um
or is it equal
you know
it's it's hard because i've been in both
situations where
i will i really like the dude and i'll
be like you know what i'ma wait and i've
waited and then i've been in another
situation where i'm like oh i really
like to do but i'm like you know what
let's do it and like it happens
and it's just like
i couldn't tell you why i waited with
one and why i didn't wait with the other
one were you equally attracted to both
[Laughter]
i think
one
one more so then
the other one
i think i was more so
i was attracted to one but more
intellectually okay and then the other
one more physically than intellectually
okay so that's why earlier when you said
the ones that like have sex early
they're not respecting them so i was
like oh my gosh
wait so the one you were more attracted
to physically like was he was that the
did you sleep with him sooner
oh yeah unfortunately
no okay so it's funny because you know
what they call that in the mannose
sphere so this is like red pill kidding
well
no no no they call it like like alpha
and beta so it like depends how a girl
views the guy and it's it's kind of so
alpha's like the leader usually and
that's who like the girls are the most
attracted to and like like when i think
of an alpha because it depends on the
social circle right but like when i
think of an alpha i think of jake paul
and like his little sidekick friend in
that group i know i know neither are
like great examples but like he's the
leader he's the side does that make
sense yeah so like a lot of times like
girls will make what they call the
beta's weight and the alphas like
they sleep with right away
interesting and it's interesting because
they talk about like mating strategies
for women so like one of them is like
good genes and that's the person you're
like physically attracted to but another
one is like like parental investment so
if like you can see the kids sticking or
like the guy sticking around for the kid
and another one's like legacy so that's
like why like you don't want a guy
that's like publicly cheating on you
yeah that's why some girls will like get
will get cheated on but they'll do it in
private but if he like does it and it
becomes public like no they're out
like interesting
but it's just interesting because you
guys don't really know anything about
the red pill and so like when you guys
say stuff and it kind of aligns with
real life it's kind of interesting
um
okay
next question that i have
um
oh wait this is the wrong one
she got two phones
no this is my us phone this is my
british everyone it looks sketchy
doesn't it
um okay i know
do you want to be a burner do you guys
when you meet a guy can you tell
immediately if you would like
like date him or not
i think it depends on how long that
conversation lost for
so you meet him you talk to him for like
15 minutes
could you tell if you would sleep with
him or not yeah definitely right away
yeah
i don't think so
i would no
i
i think
so for me um
not that if i would sleep with them
in that 15 minutes but like
yeah like if you're gonna be like just a
cool person like okay you cool like
let's just kick it on this friend but
if i like i'm talking to you and i'm
like huh you're a very interesting
person i could see myself like just a
little bit let's see where this goes
yeah yeah i think i think so because you
can learn a lot about someone in 15
minutes if they know how to hold the
conversation yeah that depends on the
person
i think it's like i have guys that are
like immediate yeses immediate no's and
then the maybes where i can't decide
i don't know
because like they'll do one thing and
i'm like oh he's kind of he's kind of
hot and then he'll do another thing i'm
like
no the ick is real it's so real
what about you sam what up for guys is
it just immediate or that's like 10-15
seconds
it's like either hot
hot or not
you know they're hot or not and as soon
as you speak to them you know if it's
but i was in france on the weekend
and i saw a couple of girls
and they're from
california
like by the same house
as soon as they started talking their
accents and everything i was just like
nope just
these are just like exactly like that
yeah yeah white chick california girls
it was just absolutely good
yeah i was gonna ask as a guy like is
there anything so that's one thing
accent yeah outside like so let's say
the girl's hot enough like she's you
know
looks good is there anything she can do
that would be make you
outside of that
probably not
just can't have a valley girl accent
exactly that's why in the red pill
they'll be like yeah women's
requirements are like this tall this
much money this this this and men's
requirements are like hot and available
and like willing exactly
you guys never think about like other
things other than looks
when it comes to looking for a
relationship yeah okay but when you're
looking to hook up now relationship with
someone that's like
probably not a 10 out of 10 maybe like a
5 out of 10 but like they're
they have your best interest
maybe a seven out of ten not quite five
what about just a sex
[Music]
if they got good bread or good money
then yeah maybe wait so you care about a
girl's money
you both have money you both gotta
so women cannot rely on a guy it's gotta
be maybe not 50 50.
you think it should be 50 50.
maybe 60 40 to the man no i think it
should be 50 50.
for real okay
i have my own stuff you've got your own
stuff you know so if a guy
wanted to take care of you would you not
let him i'm an independent person
take care of me
guys in the video just so you know um i
will certainly let you thank you
don't don't subscribe i don't subscribe
pearl's like take care of me please so
on a first date are you splitting the
bill yeah yeah
with the whole relationship yeah
like i mean sometimes if it's safe it's
my birthday
yeah yeah or like sometimes you want to
treat me or i will treat you like but
it's not like
like joke the time i'll if if he doesn't
have money or if it's a thing like i'll
just pay for my shirt you know
i can understand that
so that's how you would do is that how
you did your eight-year relationship
yeah it's pretty pretty split yeah
do you guys think that open
relationships can work no
i agree with we've seen first hand
you you know someone no no no i
personally i don't know okay okay
talking about the recent incident
that has been going on in the details
in the news
the biggest ones
i i just think it's
is
i don't know i just think it's too much
um when it comes to open relationships
that you have you're like your main but
then you whenever you don't feel like
being with your mane you're like oh i'm
gonna go over here and over there
i just think it's too much
of a
outside outsideness coming into your
relationship because you're not only
just hooking up with that person
when you connect with somebody on that
level there's so much more stuff that
can come with it that you're taken back
to your home and you don't realize it
you're taking it back anything and
everything and is now in your
your safe space your house
and
it's just
stirring up your relationship you're
like what's going on here
and then you have different things like
manifesting in the wrong way to where
it never would have happened if you
didn't have that other person coming in
no and i feel like open relationships
it's always like the person who started
it kind of wants out i think
did they ever went
i think in could work for some people
personally not me but i can understand
why some people do it are you guys
jealous
people that can do it
no no no
in your relationships are you guys
i'm actually not jealous no
no i think i let like whatever actions
they do
i go off that like i'm not gonna be like
i'm gonna go for your phone yeah cause
what's the point like yeah you don't
wanna be with me just bye you're not
like there's no point of because i see
some relationships where like the girl's
like you can't do this you can't do that
like
i'm not going to stop you from
going to parties yeah having friends
that are females and stuff like that but
if you disrespect it then that's when
yeah that's where the problem is yep
yeah i think if you're jealous there's
issues of trust there yeah yeah
it could be an insecure issue in your in
yourself as well big time
um they're telling me the audio's
low hold on
i used to be jealous though okay guys
tell me if the audio is better here
tell me in the chat okay
um
do you tell your significant other if
someone hits on you in a relationship
you think you should i mean i don't
think i should but i'll tell it as a
joke
hey yo guess what this person said to me
that like that way but not to be like oh
my gosh like you should be concerned
everybody's hitting on me like
defend me like no no i think the other
day one i was wearing like a naruto
hoodie right and then some guy was like
oh i really like your hoodie and i'm you
know how i am with anime i'm like you
like anime what the hell and he's like
oh you look really pretty like what's um
what's your name and i was like sorry i
have a boyfriend and then on the phone i
was like to my boyfriend this guy just
hit on me but
like he was he drawed me in because of
anime like how dare he did it
that's the kind of that's how i was
saying yeah yeah yeah be like oh this
guy
i would like rather not know
like really unless there was someone i
know but like like why do i need to know
that information
like if it's someone i don't know and
you'll never see again like why do i
need to
[Music]
why do i need to know
it's good to know it's good to talk but
it just means there's open communication
and the trust
he's solid
if you know
someone's hit on your fella and he's
just part them off
you know he's
he's there for you yeah and i can go my
life without knowing that
what do you mean could be sleeping
around he could be i mean i would hope
not
well i don't think him telling me if
someone hit on like hit on him is
indicative of him cheating well some
guys actually do that to get the girls
jealous their girlfriend's jealous
really yeah they'll like test you
do they
think they're like makeup girls
wow probably
they probably also can't imagine that
many girls are approaching guys like i
just can't imagine it's that many
surprises really
really actually you tell me you tell me
yeah that girl's approach guys really
you get approached a lot
a bit really okay
no nothing again nothing against like
you it's just more like i always hear
from guys like they don't get approached
and they like wish more girls would
approach them so that's interesting to
hear
my brother bro like my friends always
like to me oh my god your brother's so
cute
like my brother's there
they're very trash like they're really
into girls so they i don't know i don't
know if they approach if it's like
mutual but they my brother
especially my oldest brother he has
loads of like girls just always going up
to him wow even my friends they're just
like oh let's cheat
no
i feel like that's a girl thing because
all my sister's friends
suddenly said something like oh he's
cute he's cute all that stuff is a girl
thing because i have my friends do that
oh my gosh your brother i'm like dude do
you guys do that like if you think like
if you had a friend yeah yeah yeah
manager at work
oh
no my manager at work uh was checking
out my sister the other day
my brothers are crazy wow you think she
are you going to set it up or
she's married
with two kids oh
okay don't don't set it up
okay um
okay girls have you ever led someone on
because you enjoyed the attention
girls love attention
that is true um
no
i don't think i said no i don't think
i've led someone on but i feel like
sometimes guys like
reach when it's not there yeah but
you're like just being nice
you know what i mean yeah but sometimes
guys think you're flirting with them
because you're being nice yeah see i've
been i've been put in those situations
where they're like oh like oh and
i want to take you out like i really
like him like oh or you have a friend
that you know or you have a guy friend
that you like know likes you but you've
told him like it's not gonna be anything
so but you you want to be friends like
you like the fret like yeah do you think
like do you think that's wrong as a guy
i think just
society sees a guy and a girl out these
day and they just think they're
immediately dating like a guy and a girl
can't be out just as friends
it's just why some girls can be friends
to be honest exactly
go for dinner just as friends just as
guys with guys and girls
i think they can but i think there's a
certain point where it's weird
i i don't know exactly what the point is
but
yeah i think if you're hanging out like
with one person all the time and it's a
guy and a girl like one of them probably
likes the other one yeah i used to have
this okay me and this guy we were
friends for years we was friends for
four or seven years i mean
it did become weird that's why i'm not
friends with him no more but
okay before that we had a really good
friend yeah but he liked you the whole
time so you just proved my point if it
was the whole time it could have been
what made it weird
okay as a guy as a guy do you think
do you think he liked her the whole time
do you think he liked her the whole time
there was a point that was yeah there
was probably an ulterior motive
somewhere the whole time yeah
was that what he said seven years so his
frustrations started showing
okay we got guys thank you for the super
chat
okay ladies have you ever gone on a date
um when you knew beforehand you didn't
like the guy come on be honest
um
i've never gone on a date where i knew
beforehand i didn't like the guy but i
it was in the maybe category where i was
like
but in hindsight like i think if a guy's
a maybe it's probably no
but it wasn't like i was thinking
that
oh i don't like him it would never
happen i was thinking it might happen
but i don't know
you think that counts what do you think
if you're saying maybe it's a no
no but not at the time at the time i was
like i don't know maybe
but you just trying to test the wolves
yeah yeah because i was just trying to
see like maybe there's something there
but then you go on the date and you're
like yes it did yeah
honestly i don't
i don't think so because if
if i've already like in my mind
like made up that like
this isn't going to go anywhere i'm
i won't even like go out on a date with
you out to dinner and nothing because
i'm going to be i'm hiking going to be
irritated the whole time like why
why and like if the conversation like we
haven't had a conversation beforehand
it's not like flowing it's just going to
be dead there and be like
all right so
how about them dodgers like how are they
doing yeah yeah
well if he has money
you make a good point what if okay what
if you get asked on a date too
to like the nicest restaurant in london
the shop i don't know what that is
you're not a big
pointy bang
the really big point okay he'll take you
i got it better he'll take you courtside
to whatever your favorite basketball
teams
i'll take you courtside would you go
[Music]
forget about this person no because then
i don't know that's
ah that's hard i feel so guilty yeah
because if i if i physically don't like
him
like i don't i don't think i could hide
it sometimes yeah
no i see i want to act like i'm a better
person than i am
i'm really tempted right now to be like
but i'ma just
basketball wouldn't do it for me i don't
really watch basketball and play it but
i think if it was something like luke
combs front row like my favorite country
artist
yeah
let's go
that's interesting
if it's something to do with something
that i like like anime and that's a lot
of money and i can't afford it go to
comic-con yeah like in the states and be
like hey i want to take you to comic-con
and say i'm going to that thing
yeah that's so bad but i would
it would be the same for guys like if
the girl has money yeah
so if she was like an old lady
there's an age limit but yeah
let's see yeah it also depends on looks
like she can be 40 and still look good
let's say 50. 50. yeah
but she's really independent what's your
what's your favorite sports team
what's your like what's your thing music
football so front row football
yeah
question would you date someone that
your friend had hooked up with no
friends friends of friends no no okay it
was one time that your friend doesn't
care anymore it was like one time a long
time ago
like i feel like that's their properties
oh that's very small
i'm trying to think if i have
i have a different is it type
is it they've just hooked up or they
like no no they just hooked up it was
like one time a long time that's kind of
how i feel like if it was just once twi
like a couple times if they'd been in a
relationship what about when your friend
comes to your house like say you guys go
into a relationship with your friends
like i don't wanna i think those things
will turn me crazy i think like i'm not
a crazy person but i think that could
make me insecure and gender so i'll just
say i think i think if it was a long
time ago
and like that and that person has like
moved on and i trust both of them like
i i wouldn't care whatever
i probably wouldn't care i'd be like and
how close is the front that's the other
like okay because i was thinking about
it my sister cooked
cooked
sisters to me though like my sisters and
i have friends that are like sisters to
me but i guess there's like
acquaintances like say someone from like
you yeah yeah like we say hi and bye
that's a bit yeah
yeah yeah like my friends
it doesn't matter he's like unless
there's been a relationship there
if they've just put it up though what if
there was a relationship it was like two
months and like it wasn't really that
serious
it depends how deep he felt over here
yeah
that could happen
oh my god actually my brother did that
he he's probably going to marry a girl
his friend dave
she's great though i understand why he
did it i mean that happened to my
brother he was dating this girl um
for
how many years i think like two years
maybe and then
then breaking up she ends up
starting to date a dude he went to high
school with and now they're married with
kids
and he like played basketball friends
with him and everything and like knew
him like grew up with him and everything
and they she went and dated him and now
they're married i'm like so there's a
girl in my friend group in college and
this guy
slept with like because there was like
10 of us on the volleyball team okay and
to be fair it was a small school
um but he slept with
[Applause]
between two and three other girls before
they dated within like the same couple
of months
and they dated for two years i don't
think he cheated on her as far as i know
but
i mean like what can you do with but it
was just like casual like it was like
like he hooked up with the other girls
like casually it was just like once yeah
twice maybe but then her he like dated
her
like what can you do about someone's
past and you like just so happen to find
out like oh that's your friend oh how do
you know that oh you like messed around
a couple years back what are you gonna
do oh my gosh i'm gonna break up with
you yeah like it's just like
things happen
like amani said if it's like close close
i'd be like nah like yeah that's too
close to home
yeah um
what type of women do you think men
should avoid and vice versa
let's think
of women
um
i don't know
do you want to answer this first and
then
it's time for women that men should
avoid well you would do what type of men
should women avoid what i've been
mentioned women yeah
like
like you're saying earlier like the
alpha type jake pauls
the alpha types yeah you know he's
sleeping around oh okay yeah because
they're going to get cheated
there's no loyalty there yeah
so on the same token do you think men
should avoid hoes
that's right for a relationship yes yeah
i'm gonna say that just to hook up yeah
let's get like wife first that's what i
thought
i had
no i literally had this conversation on
my channel before i feel like hoes get
wiped up faster than fruits it's usually
because they're pretty like
as we no i swear to god
look at girls that are like
hot exactly yeah yeah so if they're 10
out of 10
and they're good in bed
and then they have a little bit of a
personality i feel like a guy that's the
thing most pretty girls don't have a
personality
but no well because what how is the guy
really gonna know the girls no but the
guys
yeah so the guys don't know but i feel
like
like
actually
normally like hoes get wiped up faster
than prudes it's just the hose that can
hide it
yeah
because like how was the guy gonna
survey like
here's a survey like some girls you can
tell right like some girls like make it
really obvious but some
so have you ever met a girl where you're
like shocked yeah that she like she
looks one way and you're like completely
shocked yeah
yeah i've been
who you don't just say names but like oh
i can't think of it off the top of my
head but i know i've been shocked
you're like that wow okay i have
i have definitely
oh i know one
i know
so
it was someone i went to college with
um
she's
how do i explain it she's not like
if there's a spectrum like uglies on
this side like drop the gorgeous on the
side she's like right in the middle
she's she's cute she's cute yeah
i don't know
what
type of magic she had but she
had them on rotation and i'm like
first for sex or relationships for sex
i'm like okay well that doesn't count
i think as a girl that does not count if
you have a guy in rotation for sex no no
not a guy
no like guys like that like if she had
guys lining up to like wife her like
make that her their girlfriend but
okay
like i feel like that's not like i i
mean you could do that
easy
are those girls in the middle
the ones with maybe a slightly lower
self-esteem
so they just
lower their standards and go with any
guy
i don't know i don't know the way she
feels they can get her like she's pretty
she's cute she's not bad mm-hmm
so they'll go for it yeah you know those
girls that are like um
like they glowed up loads when they were
like probably coming up to college and
stuff like that and
now they can get any guy that they want
but their self-esteem so low from like
back in the days maybe they just get
bullied because i don't know and then
they start going through a phase where
they're like sleeping with loads of guys
loads of guys because they're like oh i
could get those any guy i want now yeah
they get one guy two guy and then he
just keeps on rolling
okay question for the girls
yes this is a would you take a guy okay
that's
how tall how tall are you like five ten
five eleven okay so let's say he's one
to two inches shorter than you
okay but but hear me out
really good in bed
or or a guy that's
let's say five inches taller than you
but but terrible and bad
which one are we picking yeah which one
do you pick
because i heard i heard when we get to
30
girls shrink two
only shrink one inch that's what i had
will be it will be similar
you say 50 oh i was like
same question okay would you take a girl
that's an eight model pretty like
prettiest girl you've ever been with but
she just lays there
[Music]
or or but she's a model she's stunning
stunning but okay or
or the girl or a girl she's like
cute but like on the girls you've slept
with she'd be on the lower end but you
know what i mean like kind of
like i don't know what i don't know what
that looks like
but when you think of the girls you've
slept with like she'd be on the like
lower end
but the best sex in your life like yeah
looks like the sex
so you pick the girl that's good at sex
so then by that do you think sex in some
instances makes guys fall in love and
therefore hoes get wiped up faster than
improvements
yeah yeah
[Music]
honestly
like my brother sometimes he comes back
here and he's like amani i'm in love and
i'm like wait she just had a good show
yeah yeah
you just met this girl how are you in
love and he's like i'm in love trust me
like guy doesn't usually come off the
couch like come home and like i'm in
love like they don't usually do that but
i guess
it has something to do with
you know their effects what do you think
comes first sex or relationships i think
it depends on the gender
for for women well it's like both of
them because they both have to get into
their relationships
one's more important than the other
depending on gender because i feel like
relationship well i don't know it could
be different for each person right
well you're 15 so yeah
i would think
[Music]
but like in general because again you're
you're the girl i'm sure you listen to
all of your friends problems about
relationships so when most of your
friends if you think of like 10 of your
friends
what percent like do you think the
relationship came first
oh
before the sex
the sex came faster and then the
relationship yeah not melting
i feel like nowadays i mean not just
nowadays but i feel like people
are like
if what if and i've heard this like what
if i marry them and they're like
horrible in bed and i have to spend the
rest of my life with them
well i feel like if if girls were
virgins and they wouldn't even know
yeah that that too
like but i mean it's like different now
but i feel like it worked before because
like how
how would you know yeah they were bad
and bad if you've never had anyone else
what if it was just hiding yeah
that was so that's just unfortunate
or what if okay what if you wait till
you're married okay ready you wedding
night
microphone oh my days
are you leaving
wait what
you wait till you're married micro micro
surely you would have seen it at least
no no no i say i say like you're a
christian couple wait till you're
married like like i don't even see
people married these christian couples
they they might be having sex but they
they fondling and feeling around a
little bit surely yeah oh yeah
i went to catholic school i'm like
how is that better
at this point you might you might as
well just do the thing
literally
like so you could tell your husband look
it i'm a virgin
not not boss
oh my goodness literally um
that's
what was your original question
okay christian couple you wait till
you're married wedding night micro
anomaly
you're not you're what
a nominee you know
you're out
but there had to be something that
made you fall in love with that person
enough to marry the rest of your life
come on come on i don't know what i
would tell a dude to do if that happened
too
get some drugs
better get some viagra get a little pump
fix it somehow
ah
so you might stay you're thinking about
it
i feel like i feel like you think you
should stay yeah but like part of you is
like
because then you would never you would
never have good sex again the rest of
your life
but if i was a virgin i wouldn't i
wouldn't know i mean
you can still be good with his hands
yeah i think i think you're gonna have
to rely on toys at that point yeah
that's it hands tongues i mean
the motion of the ocean if he can work
with what he got
it would just be hard because
i don't know
i got questions i don't know enough
about that
i mean
i don't know
i mean you should still be able to have
kids maybe not the
natural way
but
but it would just be hard because if i
if i
didn't have sex it was a virgin didn't
know what nothing felt like
and i
am in love with this person enough
just for them being them and i marry
them and it just so happens that he
wasn't blessed as much as other people
and
i would i would probably stay because
i'd be like oh
well do you so did you grow up in a
christian like household do you wish you
waited
sometimes i do i wish i did yeah
actually sometimes i do and i'm like
because i grew up catholic yeah and i
was like i kind of wish i did it's
a lot emotional
what makes you wish that
a lot of stuff for me
um i wish i would have waited because i
know that when i do
engage with someone sexually i'm
i haven't really
got to know them know them as i wish i
would have and now
i it's like confused emotions like okay
like i said earlier do i really like you
or do i just like the stuff that we do
together
and so it's like if i
would have waited i never would have
that like emotional like confusion like
okay
what what is this is it true emotion or
is it just sexual emotion
well and it's like
i don't know i feel like your virginity
is like a special like i genuinely think
it's a gift you give to someone
like
and i think like i wish i could have
given that to the person i marry
like genuinely but does that depend if
the first time was a hookup or actually
in a relationship
um
well yeah well i know i think some girls
don't treat it as a gift yeah so like
i it's like
you could have something that's worth
like a ton of money and you give it away
for free
but i still think it's a gift right but
the person like you're getting doesn't
mean like like i could have a prada bag
right and i give it to someone that like
doesn't care or like pro you don't mean
like and you just give it to them they
don't think it's worth anything because
like you just gave it away
but it doesn't take away the fact that
it's valuable
you know
so i wish i did but i can't do anything
now so i'm here
there's a show um that was on
abc now it's like free form in the
states and it's called jane the virgin i
don't know if you guys have heard of it
yeah and she had
i think her mom or her grandmother gave
her a flower that represented her
virginity and throughout the show she
always talks about it and like thinks
about like losing her virginity and how
the flower is gonna like burn up and
like disintegrate
and so
when she did i can't remember if she was
married or it happened before she got
married to her husband like she was like
looking at her flower and she was like
the flower i can now like open it and
like give it away or whatever and so
that's what made me think of that just
like as a gift it is um and i've thought
about it since i've been older i'm like
man it would be cool to be able to
like
give that to someone just be like
this is all yours
i have friends that like waited till
they were married and it's just like
i don't know i just think
there's something about like doing that
on your wedding night for the first time
versus like
like you've done it before like this is
something you've done how you know
if you think about it think about like
the person that
you just have
like great connection there's this like
great across the board you guys never
have sex but you like know how like sex
is and you get to your wedding night how
just like astronomical that's gonna be
and just how like you guys are connected
on all these other levels and then you
get to your wedding night and you guys
connect on that sexual level as well
it's gonna be off the charts yeah
but i don't think men really value
virginity like they used to to be honest
because
and the reason like the reason i think
this because i think they would prefer
someone like more on the pure side but
i think of men valued virginity you
would see the men with the most options
picking virgins and they don't
like you know the men that can date
anyone like why don't is it because they
can't find them
or is it that's like because that could
be like option one is they can't find
them but you'd imagine like if you're a
millionaire billionaire whatever like
like they have to there has to be one
so i don't i don't know what you guys
think let me know in the chat but it
doesn't seem like what do you think like
does that matter to you i mean i'd
question how many
virgins are out there that's true
true versions i thought in your
basketball team are there any
in your volleyball team yeah yeah yeah
yeah
no i i know there's yeah there's someone
on volleyball who is i wouldn't i don't
think she'd want people to know who it
is
but yeah
more than one actually too yeah yeah but
i was i was like that was shocking to me
because i don't
know any like at in the states i didn't
know anybody yeah i have a friend who
um
oh wait how old is she she was
25
when she lost her virginity
so like two years ago
just lost her virginity i couldn't
imagine wait until now
i
i
how old were you
i was
uh
21 you're 21. i don't remember if i was
19 or 20. i was a sophomore in college
no i was actually older than the people
around here
yeah uk is here they're cool
yeah usually like 16 20 yeah 16 yeah but
i feel like 1920 like i was like the
last one out of all my friends like i
was like i feel like in school people
look 14
yeah yeah yeah yeah 14 15. uk is savage
oh my god
i feel like yeah okay yeah like
guys usually listen you're like 13.
that's what i think guys well you know
the rate of male virgins is going up
like we have a lot of in school there
are a lot of like 13 14 year olds
sleeping about 18 year old girls oh yeah
ew
that's like a predator maybe 17 not by
18 but yeah
i mean it's like a freshman
and uh i don't know a senior in high
school
i think it's different though when yeah
yeah i think it's one thing in college
but i don't know there's just something
like you're so mentally different at 13
to 18
14. that good for girls they're like
19 18 they go for girls they're like 15
16. yeah yeah
okay one in three men between the ages
of 18 to 30 are either a virgin or
hasn't had sex in the past year say them
again one in three men between the ages
of 18 to 30 are either a virgin or
haven't had sex in the past year that's
a lot i wouldn't actually be surprised
you know guys like to lie about how much
well i don't think i think it's
it's like a smaller and smaller
percentage of men are having sex with
more women
because you think about it like if you
want a guy that's over six foot that's
only 15 percent of men no i'm serious
like like and you hear a girl say he has
to make this much money and this much
like whatever
like
and you add that on top of each other
it's a very small percentage of guys
yeah so like most guys aren't having sex
with that many people
would you actually would you agree with
that or no i don't know what your friend
group's like so it also depends who
you're around would you say one in three
of your friends have not had sex in the
past year
are you that one
definitely not no
no
[Music]
everyone's smashing he's like i don't
know who these losers are
yeah i don't know
maybe maybe not one in three maybe like
one in
six seven one in six seven has it had
sex in the past year you would say in
your friend group
okay
five dollar super chat from mr got
plenty ladies in a relationship with a
tall handsome successful man that you
know
wait that you want you know what your
man's role is and what your role is in a
relationship oh so he's asking do you
know so
guy that you're dating do you know what
do you think your roles and
responsibilities are in a relationship
if he like has his
like i do some cooking sometimes he does
some cooking sometimes i do the cleaning
sometimes he disagrees sometimes i feel
like that's so inefficient
no i'm like like i'm just gonna finish
all the cooking and cleaning
well i would like okay because my
thought like why
there's cooking right and let's say like
fixing the car
why would i get 50
good at these skills why wouldn't i just
get really good at one and he gets
really good at the other i don't need
him to fix my clock i get go to a
mechanic yeah i know but like why would
i when he could do it and like why don't
we do it
i mean
nowadays don't know how to do that
that's true we could this is just the
example i'm using but you we could use a
different example but like my thing is
like
i would just rather be efficient and
then i get really good at cooking i'll
do all the cooking you can get good at
something else and you do that but if
you break down on the motorway do you
not want to know how to change your own
tire
oh my god i'm the most resourceful
person i'm going to tell you this story
i'm the most
i don't care what anyone says i'm the
most resourceful person alive okay
when i was like 20 or 21 okay i was
going to see this boy that i was
obsessed with
and but i was staying at my parents
house and so like i didn't tell them
like clearly like i'm not yeah and
anyways so i'm driving to his house at
like like late right and i i run into a
pothole and i get a flat tire so i'm
like what do i do i i i'm
i'm i i can't change a tire
i can't call my dad because he'll be
like what are you doing in freaking like
45 minutes from the house because i went
to college like an hour away oh okay and
so like a lot of people lived within
like two hours you know i'm saying like
i lived like an hour from the school
like i think he lived like an hour in a
different direction so
what i did was i was like okay i'm by
myself um
and he should have came in hindsight
what was i do but he was he was really
far like because i wasn't close enough
like
i don't know like it didn't make sense
for whatever reason so what i did was i
called the police and i was like i'm
scared i'm like by myself can someone
come and like like sit with me like i
don't want to like whatever
so the police officer came
and i was like i bet you the police
officer knows how to change a tire
and and the police it was a girl and i
was like oh no my chances just got lower
but no this lady literally changed my
tire
and so i was like i am the most
resourceful person alive i
who else would have thought of that at
least they didn't tell you oh you know
this is not a part of our job
description because i've had that happen
to me my tire got flat i tried to change
it but it fell off the jack and so i had
to call the police
and they're like you know this isn't our
job description i was like can you just
help me please like it's midnight i need
to go home i need to pick up my brother
blah blah but
um i don't think going back to your
question ah
i don't think it should be 50 50.
like i'm gonna
i'm gonna have my own money but
it's like hard because like
it's his money your money
i would say in certain situations yes if
we're doing things that involve uh
both of us whoever is whoever's making
more i would say that yes but if it's
like
oh
i want to go shopping i'm going to use
my money because i'm not going to i'm
not going to take away from
his income to support
my life what i need
so that's why i think it should be
whoever doesn't matter whoever's making
more money i think they have more
responsibilities than whoever's making
less i agree with that in terms of
money-wise we're making the same
yeah i kind of prefer a more traditional
relationship to be on like yeah like at
the 50-50 thing although i don't i don't
know why i just don't like it i don't
like the choice in a way because i'm
just like
i'm i'm not your mom
like you need to you need to know
like you need to know how to at least
clean up after yourself i don't know i
like like doing it for a guy like maybe
not cleaning because i'm not i'm not
i like like cooking for a guy like it
just makes me feel like i actually like
cooking a lot yeah i can't lie my
boyfriend doesn't he can cook but
it's not questionable yeah i like it i
would admire cooking more yeah but i
heart like like if i'm coming from like
say he's at home all day and i'm at work
all day yeah
yeah exactly
yep
like i would say that i think in
some instance like there could be like
evan flow like you do it one day i'll do
it the next
i feel like the only time it's not equal
is when like a female is pregnant that's
the only time outside yeah yeah
okay do the girls thank you doug for the
six dollar super chat
thank you okay
do you think do the girls on the panel
think that there's a such thing as
waiting too long 30 plus versions
virgins are usually nuts
um i think if you're 30 years old and a
virgin and looking to be married um
personally i feel like you did something
wrong like
like because you could hire a matchmaker
or like i i genuinely feel like if i
wanted to get married in the next
like year i could figure it out
yeah if i wanted to
i i mean actually
you do that okay no no because right now
right now i'm like building this stuff
right so i'm like spending a lot of time
doing youtube and like like volleyball
like i have all this stuff going on but
like if that was my number one priority
i would just like
you can go on hinge you go on like five
dates a week for a year you don't think
you'll find someone you like and you put
in your profile that you're like
marriage minded
that is i'm sure if you're really direct
about what you want you'll find other
people that want the same thing like you
don't think there's guys that want to
marry a virgin in the next year you
can't find one okay
yeah like i just
i feel like if you go looking for it the
chance of you actually connecting with
that one so if i go on five if i go on
five days a week that's like five ten
fifty that's twenty guys in a month you
don't think i'll find one i like for a
year
i wonder or are you higher if you're
[ __ ] what do you like to do higher
i just genuinely feel like if you want
to be married like like you go to your
you go to like
mutual friends you could hire a
matchmaker like there's a million so
like i don't understand how you could be
30 you've never had sex with anyone like
i just don't there's guys in the church
that want virgins like they exist
yeah i think that's the best place if
you're thirty years old
go to a church if you're not a believer
oh that's true
did you think about that
are people that aren't
religious virgins
is that's what i was just gonna say like
i wonder if like
aren't religious are they even looking
for marriage and stuff because marriage
isn't me yeah sometimes yeah that
marriage to me isn't really yeah
like you sign a piece of paper like yeah
it is signed a piece of paper for some
people
for the most part like it's usually a
religious act isn't it yeah what do you
guys think is there ever waiting too
long
for what no no do you think there's a
such thing as waiting too long 30 plus
virgins are usually nuts
um
i mean you can wait however long you
want to
how many years okay that's the year 18
that's 12 years
12 years that's what i said
like why are you in this situation i
think your selection
your
maybe she was trying to be a doctor yeah
but you're doing the whole time that
means you've been to uni you can't go
through uni culture without oh yeah
that's right like unique oh my god if
you if you're trying to be a doctor
you're surrounded by dot like
i would put me in a room with doctor
i'm gonna go to a med school one day
just
just walk in this just maybe
maybe cause i think
i think that a lot of people who like
save themselves either are doing it for
one religious reasons or their standards
are just
out of this world and
they'll they'll have guys that are
willing to
marry them willing to just give their
all to them but there's one thing that
they in their list of whatever that they
don't meet and then they just are like
no i can't marry you because you don't
make this much you don't
do this you don't do that and this is
what exactly what i want in a man
you're never going to find the perfect
person yeah
and that person's just going to be a
virgin till they die yeah
might as well sign up to be a nun
yeah
okay
so one thing that modern dating and like
hookup culture one thing that changed
the dating game forever
[Music]
is there a certain amount of time that
you would feel some type of way if your
significant other didn't post you
no
yes if it's been okay he's obviously
posting me
together for six years and he has
opposed me are you crazy
for me i don't think i'd have a problem
with that because i probably wouldn't
post them and it's not that i
wouldn't want to
i just don't
private life yeah i just don't like
other people like oh my gosh like that
like they don't know me but now that i'm
in a relationship you want to hit me up
know everything about my life the
setting like no you don't you don't need
to have anything in on this so it's just
like i'll probably i would probably do
like little sneak ones like the back of
their heads like their hand like little
stuff like that like you won't know
until you need to know
he's gonna be anonymous i think that
that was actually me and my last
like it kind of bothered me because my
last boyfriend didn't like really post
me too much no
occasion like sometimes i don't know i
it like kind of made me feel some type
of way
because i feel like what like why
you know what my
old best friend right he um
he had multiple like girls one of them
was his girlfriend and he had multiple
multiple girls like on the side here
down everywhere and that's why he didn't
post his girlfriend so i can understand
why girls will be a bit mad
a little bit crazy be like what what
yeah but it also was like i didn't trust
him so i think that was kind of more
like if he was a guy that i actually
trusted and he just wasn't on social
media like that but i feel like it's
weird when you post like
like me okay
i guess it's a double-edged sword though
now
because i don't know the person because
yeah obviously where you're very
socially active yeah that you
want to be out there you want your fella
putting you out there yeah yeah whereas
like
i know it's different but with my
relationship with my siblings
stuff i do with my sister i put on
social media more than i do with my
brother because he's not particularly
socially active stuff like that yeah
well i was just thinking that now would
be a little different like because i
think i saw the drawbacks of a public
relationship because we still like we
had a lot of posts on like my page a lot
and i kind of saw the drawbacks of that
so i think my next relationship i'd like
to be more private than i was maybe i
was wrong
sorry
me and my boyfriend obviously was
together like when he was younger yes we
just used to post like all the time when
he was like 15 16 with kids we just post
used to be like oh we're going on a date
today blah blah blah and then everyone's
kind of just in your business and then
now
like no one sees anything the only time
you'll see a post of me and him
is birthdays um my private stories on my
private instagrams and that's it because
it's just like
like say i've been posting for a little
while oh how's you and like your
boyfriend yeah
don't look at any of your business yeah
like why do you want to know
i feel like that's just something you
say though like
like
like i'll say that even if i don't care
yeah like just to be polite
or just just be polite and people would
like i swear to god i've said that
i don't know maybe i've posted something
because sometimes i'll be posting quotes
like well not now but when i was a bit
younger i used to be posting quotes they
were like oh what's happening with you
and jayden like what's going on like
have you guys broken up i'm like
well what no we haven't why i think
anything and everything after exactly
like they just want the drama and stuff
there's certain people that are not like
that obviously like yeah other people
are like very enough no i mean you
unders like you you know you get vibes
from people yeah
i was just thinking about how many times
i said that and i did not give up
it's kind of like when you say how are
you it's just like
and some people ask just to be like nosy
and i've i've been there and i'm like i
haven't seen that person on your
instagram for a minute
so how are you and so-and-so and it's
like oh we broke up i'm like oh i
already knew it but what happened
yeah
[Music]
at one point yeah i did it because i was
like i don't i don't know if y'all still
good and i don't want to ask and i was
like and you said oh yeah me and my
boyfriend i said okay you guys are still
together
at the end of a relationship
how much do you delete do you delete it
how soon do you delete it see i don't i
don't post anything on my social media
at all and so if people know that i'm
like talking to someone or dating
someone i will tell them but i won't
post it like my first boyfriend
i
i don't think i posted anything but he
hacked into my instagram and he started
posting stuff and i was like
you know what no
yeah the big red flag and so um and then
like my second one he posted stuff on
his and so everyone's like oh my gosh
i'm like we haven't even talked about
being in a relationship so what's going
on so i
i don't do anything now with snapchat
i'll do videos and like save them as
soon as we break up don't don't do
delete delete delete and so i like if we
break up you're dead like i swear to god
you're like dead to me
um well the last time it wasn't right
away because i i was debating if we were
going to get back together so i so i was
like
i'm not going to delete them yet now
what did you make them private though no
because we were still like taught like
talking a little bit so i was like i'm
going to just wait and see and as soon
as i knew um we weren't gonna get back
together i think i took everything down
the problem is we had so many videos
that sometimes like ones will come up
and i'm like oh no like i didn't take
that one down but
i think let me know if i missed any guys
because it used to be all over my
youtube
which is kind of annoying because i lost
a lot of videos i had a decent amount of
views but whatever i was like
so that's how i was like my next
relationship i'm not i'm not making no
contact
but i have to like that's long because
if i take a lot of time to make it like
i don't have to take it down later
exactly
um
okay we got two super chats
thank you um ladies on the panel um
ladies on the panel do you believe in
the concept of the wall
what does that mean okay i'm gonna give
you guys this rectal talk this is red
pill talk so
i wonder if i can
oh that's the thumbnail
the wall rollo i'm gonna see if the
chart comes up or not if it doesn't i
don't feel like finding it
um okay this is like basically a chart
that sorry chat you're not gonna be able
to see this but you guys know this is
like a chart of like women's like peak
of like their sex they call it the
sexual market value
okay so it's like basically
you're like 25 ish
20 it's like 22 i think it's like the
peak
yeah and it just like goes downhill fast
[Music]
yeah like same i'm like this is oh i
guess i'm already going down see i'm
here yeah i'm here what's the point that
like the men and women
it's like oh jess you're here on the
track
downhill let's go
and this is men they peak later in life
so they're when did they peak it's like
35
ish
yeah so yeah so they get more like
yeah because women's collagen and our
skin like breaks down faster
um and it's like it's different for
every person so obviously like if you
stay in good shape and take care of
yourself like it's gonna
like do you think jlo had the same wall
as everybody else no of course not but
this is just in general
so like
basically they're saying at
they kind of change when exactly it is
but
27 28 it's like the clock starts ticking
like faster
yeah yeah and then it's like um it's
just basically saying like girls have to
get their lives figured out before like
35 if they want to have a family and
like kids so
yeah so
but because
and then like at around like 31
ish that's when girls are like
basically
like desperate
because they need to get married like
quick yeah so like rolo would always
tell the guys to date someone between
like 25 to 28
29 because
then you have like a little more time
it's not like too rushed
but yeah
did i butcher that guys i'm sorry let me
know in the chat did i miss anything
um the wall starts after 28. yeah rolo
said 29 on a stream the other day i
think
you know technology's helping a little
bit
but
oh and because the more relationships
the girl has the more like damaged she
is basically
let me like think like kind of i think
men too like it's the same thing like
the more like the more people you're in
love with the more chances you have to
get hurt
but you also learn stuff you also get
relationship skills it's like a
multi-faceted thing but do you guys
think that's true
i'm excited for my wall actually
i'm looking i can't wait for the clock
to start ticking
get that clock going
um
i don't know i don't know if that's true
or not
i feel like it kind of is
i feel i agree with it i like
so the wall is basically saying that
like at a certain age like just
sex for women like just declines well
it's just like
like women like
women i don't think in general i think
in general honestly most people don't
look better as they get older
i think most people look better at 21
than they do at 31 like across the board
men and women
you think
i think some men look better
but i don't think most women do it all
depends
like assuming let's say they didn't i
think most people gain weight as they
get older most people but i think if you
say that
yeah but i think if you stay the same
weight like
uh 20 like a 21
because here's the thing the problem
isn't necessarily attraction for guys
it's because women have more attraction
cues so like like by the a guy that's 21
isn't going to have money so you can't
be attracted to money right but by the
time he's 31 even if he looks a little
worse like he might have money to
attract you or he might have status like
he might have built himself up but men
aren't attracted to those things like
apparently maybe you
but
but in general like men aren't attracted
to money
so like we're a guy like by 35 he has a
career that's that's attractive to us
but by 35 like the only thing we would
have more of that men value
is like maybe sex skills
but they don't they also value like
purity
you can't win as women well golly
well we can um because i mean in general
i think most girls are going to have
more options than most guys
especially if you stay in shape like the
majority of girls are overweight
like you put yourself in the top like 25
of girls just by being in shape
it doesn't it doesn't mean like
it's over it just means like your clock
starts like ticking
i think it's true
i'm excited for mine
okay um the next one five dollars from
bren brennan ocean
if the if a man was last born and spent
20 years caring
wait wait
wait wait if a man was the last boy or
she was the young why do you guys phrase
things like that like if a guy is the
youngest
if the man was last born and spent 20
years caring for his ailing parents and
therefore is a virgin is that man
undateable
um probably i'm gonna be honest it's not
because you cared for your parents or
whatever like i think that's really cute
but i think if you
had the option like i just can't imagine
that stopped you from having so like
that just sounds like an
excuse yeah like because imagine okay a
tall handsome man spent the last 20
years caring for his parents do you
really think he's going to be a virgin
what like what
age is these 20 years because he could
have been 30. he wasn't zero so like
let's even if he was 10 like if he's 20
he was probably 40. let's say 18 16.
that's still 36.
so did he just
it's like if he i can understand if he
like just stopped his life didn't do
anything
after let's say he's 18 after high
school he had to like stay and take care
of his parents 24 7. i can understand
him being a virgin that way because he
doesn't he's not able to get out and
explore or meet people because
if it's like around the clock
care yeah
then you're not going to be able to
in the middle of having sex with someone
your parent falls and you got to go pick
them up or they're like die
it's like i don't know i just hold on
one second i just have a hard time
believing like that would keep you a
virgin for 20 years
that's just a long time if
i don't i don't i don't know i could i
could see it it'd be
shocking but i could see it if that's if
that's the only thing he's doing but if
he's like
probably
if he like finished school when he went
to work
yeah
yeah that's what i'm like
you have to go to the grocery store to
get food like there's there's people
everywhere yeah
i don't know that's interesting so would
that be undateable to you
it doesn't it's not to me it sounds like
you just couldn't get girls
[Music]
if i'm attracted to him then
yeah teach him
yeah when do you guys think is the right
time to post someone on social media
after you get a ring
yup
yup
when i'm walking down be like it's my
husband now
you thought i was single out here
yeah yeah
we were
would you as a guy feel some type of way
if you're dating a girl for a year she
never posted you or would you not care
yeah it depends on the person how
socially active they are if they are
posting stuff out with our girls all the
time it's like hang on why aren't you
posting anything at me i feel like once
you become like an exclusive couple
at that point something needs to go on
social media then facebook officials
i mean facebook doesn't count
i'd say a couple months like
three four months maybe
of being exclusive or like dating and
hooking up i think that's early
is it
well
i don't know
um
[Music]
say three four months for me i don't
know i don't really
it's a different now because now i'm
like doing this on youtube so it's just
and the last one was so
out there yeah that i don't
i don't know what it would be in the
future i have to think about it like
surely if you're in a relationship and
you're exclusive and you've been
together a few months surely you've done
something worthwhile putting on social
media yeah
even if it's not just to show off
your guy or your girl
you've surely done something
that you want to put out there
i've been somewhere
[Music]
yeah that's true
um
okay are thirst traps okay in a
relationship
no because who are you who are you
trying to trap yeah if you're in a
relationship like what's the what's the
point of it but a girl can just post
anything right and then it could
automatically be a first try it all
depends on how she's posing in it or
like how she
could just be like and then like a guy
would like
but that that's not considered a thirst
trap now if you if you did this and your
titties was eye and your booty that
you're like that's up there i'm talking
like bikini like like or you you you
know
you you know
but i'm just like there's that's just
some girl's personalities there yeah
because
my friend's in a long relationship and
she would post like
revealing yeah her bikini picture but it
never really like
it never really came across as like
that's the first one and she just has
like she's
yeah
and she just like
i just feel like that's kind of like
fishing
like fishing for new because what else
are you posting it for
i mean if i can't lie attention yeah
attention yeah if they're in a
relationship okay so social media is all
about attention yeah but it isn't yeah i
know but isn't that like shouldn't you
not be seeking attention for that sort
of thing when you're in a relationship
no but everyone's just always fishing
for like still regardless of
relationship status you ever have a
basketball wives saying like oh he gets
attention from women i wish i had
attention from men and you're
married to one of
one of the uh
greatest shooters in the game and what
it is it just doesn't make sense but
like no matter then you just shut down
red table talk
but like what if like you're working out
a lot
and it's like it's not revealing but
it's like um
i think it's one thing if you're a
trainer but
no i just think if you're in a
relationship you shouldn't be seeking
attention from the opposite sex
like men or women i don't think men
should be posting like
shirtless selfies just because you're
posting doesn't mean you're seeking your
attention what you just said it's
literally it's just the content you like
to put out there yeah but it's just you
you feel like you you literally just
said it's seeking attention that's what
you jut like
you just
and you're really happy about it you
want to just share it exactly
that's what i can see so what would you
be getting what would you be getting
when you share but it's like it's
something that makes you happy it goes
along with the the post and the caption
but then then it goes back to you
no i was just in say like
you know how i don't know if they still
do it but like how people would post
like a very like sexual picture and
they'd be like philippians 4 13 i can do
all things through christ strengthens me
like have a scripture underneath it and
it's like the picture and the caption
don't match but if you're like if you're
posting like a um a shirtless picture
and you say underneath it like oh i've
been working out for
don it's just like an inspirational post
then
i would say that that's that's okay
because you're not trying to seek
attention more so like i could i mean i
could see like maybe a before and after
shot of like you being fat and then not
fat but i just think in a relationship
you shouldn't be like seeking out
attention from the opposite i wouldn't i
wouldn't say you're seeking no attention
i'm still on this because i'm just like
you know okay you know i'm kind of like
i'm not at my body state right now but
you see after i go to the gym and i get
into the state that i want to be in
mm-hmm i won't be posting like bikini
[ __ ] i'm not comfortable with that
yeah yeah i'll be person whatever and
it's not even about attention i'm just
like i want to get that it's like a goal
within myself i just want to and i'm
going to be happy about it
okay but then what would what would
happen when you put it on instagram
so like
so then why not just keep it in your
camera roll
if it's not about attention i just i
just want it to be out there because
today for what
it's like
revolves around okay so when i graduate
i'm gonna post that because i'm proud of
that all right when i graduate i'm going
to post that on social media nothing's
going to happen but i'm proud of that
achievement yeah
that's one of the one of the right
examples no i understand but like i mean
this is someone i live on the internet
but i like putting on a show like i
enjoy i enjoy like i yeah like that's
partially it's for me my instagram is
not filled with people because my
instagram's private yeah i'll show you
right now i have 350 people in my have
you
from the shell no just in general oh
okay 350 people in my request because
she's personally i don't know you
actually have to be on my social media
so yeah
she does have a very like yeah i know
you have a very tame social media apart
from tick tock obviously because that's
just like anyone you're on tick tock
yeah i gotta follow you
but um
yeah so my social media is kind of just
my friends my family
uh like acquaintances from high school
and stuff like that it's not people like
majority of the people that
have tried to like chat to me in that
kind of that kind of way is on my block
list
so the people that i am sharing my stuff
with yeah are going to be people that
are going to be like oh you're so sexy
bro yeah so
i just don't really get the vibe that
you're a super attention seeking like
type of girl
no but i'm talking about
like there's traps you know like i like
you know come on you know you're not
posting that i was kind of waiting for
you to do that
you you you know you know you know what
i'm doing
no i do know you
i do know what you mean but sometimes
that could be like sometimes a first
trap for one person could be just like
the person that's posting it is probably
like oh i like this picture let me post
it and then like of other people will be
like oh she's showing this she's thrown
that she's so attractive blah blah blah
like some men's like sexualized girls
like
when girls are doing something so
innocent sometimes
some she's not wrong sometimes i feel
like it all comes down to like your
motive behind your post yeah
yeah you can have a bikini a bikini
picture and this person's just posting
it just because
they yeah they wanted to show like oh
i'm in california on the beach santa
monica roller coaster and then they just
wanted to post that but then you have
other ones who
want to seem to say it's the same exact
picture
but
they wanted to show off their body
wanted to get a couple likes couple dms
from it i'm in california hit me up or
to party like stuff like that and so i
think it it all depends on the motive
behind the post because you can't you
can't control what other people think it
is or what other people see you can only
control what you're doing and how
you do it
um
okay question
is responding so if someone dm's you
flirtly like you know
[ __ ] slides in right and you say i have
a man
all right
you're not you're not kidding me
if you if you respond i have a boyfriend
is that cheating no no you're telling
them because yeah but some people would
say why respond at all
yeah sometimes i just block them yeah
yeah because like why would like because
they'll say like if you respond i have a
boyfriend it's because they want to keep
the door open a little bit they want
them to know that's why they're not
responding
is this just like a random person or
this is like a known sort of person like
a friend of a friend it could be either
a friend of a friend like it's just you
don't respect yeah
um
let's let's go both let's go random
person then you just ignore it yeah it's
not cheating but it's just like yeah so
that's an unnecessary message to send
yeah
but maybe it's just someone's conscious
and their moral to just like not ignore
something yeah i know sometimes i feel
bad for like
i'm one of those people that reply
really fast so i feel bad for like
so i'll be like nah i have a boyfriend
sorry
how
important is sex in a relationship
would you break up with someone for bad
sex
if everything else was there
there's a chance yeah
yeah
yeah i think
i think
uh you give it time yeah you talk
but then new things you build the like
that connection outside of sex mart i
think there's a chance that they can
that's what i feel like
yeah i feel like you could get better
that's what i would say
it's not something that's always going
to be bad yeah
but let's say it's bad for six months
but everyone has their needs and desires
and you just gotta talk about it and if
your partner isn't gonna change to meet
those needs and desires then
you can't stick with that is girls just
laying their comment i don't know i hear
this from guys all the time they're like
she just like lays there
do something you're not a dead fish
it's not all my job to do
i don't understand how you just lay
there just like a just the girls
actually do that like is that actually i
don't i don't i don't know
i don't know because i don't understand
how this is how just laying there like
just
how do you enjoy just learning yeah not
not doing i don't know this is just what
i hear from guys
they'll say like she just like lays
there
oh actually oh i just remembered i heard
from a girl
years ago
this is years ago like when i was eight
okay it's not years ago but when i was
18
i was having a conversation with a girl
and then she was just like i was talking
about sex and she was like yeah i just
kind of just lay there i was like isn't
that really really boring for you but
then again she only just like lost her
virginity so she didn't know
right so i was like isn't that really
like boring and she's like no the guy
i'm with just
wants me to lay there
around
that's like oh interesting
i started talking about i was like
that's not how i do it
yeah no no what do you guys think about
being friends with exes on social media
because to me again you're dead to me
like
if i'm especially if i'm in a
relationship you're like
yeah dead
um
are you guys oh actually question are
you guys friends with any of your ex
you're in a little i think it doesn't
count for me because i was like this was
like when was like 14 right right it
doesn't count but yeah of course wait
yeah
um no i'm not
like the ones that i've dated no i'm not
don't have them on any social media
they're both as far as i know married so
happy i could help you get married
ah
i was just thinking about like i have a
couple that are married
it's always the next girl yeah literally
but i'm like i didn't want to be with
them anyway so go ahead have fun
so would you care like if your part if
your partner was friends with their exes
on social media
[Music]
i don't think i would care it all
depends on like depends if they're like
liking and commenting on stuff yeah if
they're still like
flirting back and forth i'd be like no
so you would say no yeah
you don't care
i'm trying to think
because it would have to be you can't
like it's hard because you're trying to
think of yeah like
i don't know okay yeah
yeah it doesn't bother me doesn't it
unless they are commenting on like every
picture yeah like in every post
then it's a bit like depends on it yeah
what's that about then snapchat's a bit
more personal i think yeah
you should be having a snapchat yeah
yeah yeah
yeah yeah
you shouldn't be messaging each other
yeah yeah none of that
snapchat is a little sketch
instagram's more like anyone kind of has
instagram yeah everyone so i'm not
really fussed with that
yeah i know
yeah that's kind of the only one you
shouldn't have each other's numbers
though
would you be okay with him catching up
with an ex
why do you need to catch up
what you need to catch up about i'm
coming too
you can catch up together
what y'all need to catch up about yeah
but what if it happened like they were
friends like years ago what if they were
friends before they got together yeah
that's what i thought too yeah not gonna
be friends anymore
i think it depends on the breakup mm-hmm
yeah what if it was if it was like it
was quite a mutual breakup and stuff
like that but it's like okay we don't
see this working there's just our
separate ways
our lives don't
work together and this relationship
doesn't work anymore but you can still
be friends yeah yeah
now if i if
and like i get a pretty like
yeah
like oh
no we're not
that's never gonna happen been there
done that and i get that vibe from them
i'm like okay cool like i trust you that
nothing's gonna happen but if i feel
like homegirl still has a little bit of
like
yeah liking towards him i'll be like no
she can come here i can cook dinner
everything but no
cause then it gets it's not that i don't
trust him it's just i
i wouldn't want to put him in a
situation that i know is going to
turn out bad because of
the other person how they still feel
when you also like
like i feel like as a girl like you're
not naive to how guys are yeah and how
they just want to screw everything
and so like
i feel like guys can just be put in the
wrong situ like they put themselves a
lot of times in the wrong situation but
like why would you put yourself in that
situation yeah
like that something could happen you
know
are you going to stay friends with your
ex
she wants to
know
from you no
you guys talk you ever eat together or
whatever you don't eat together
she tries doing like stuff like that but
i mean once i move out
get written i'm not going to be trying
to keep communication
i'm not going to be messaging her to
make plans or anything like that mm-hmm
she's probably going to still be
messaging me
but black
is it a red flag if a girl has a lot of
male friends
[Music]
no
um
it can be if
you're good
um
yeah yeah
i go and talk i need to think
i would say
no
because of
my life and how
i was brought up and who i was brought
up around
brothers a lot of guy friends play
sports is that in the third so
a lot of my like close close friends
like i have a friend that i talk to
a lot and he's a guy and so i don't
think
i don't think it's a bad thing it all
depends on
okay is he your guy friend just because
you guys are friends or have you guys
like had a pass and you guys have just
been like just the in between like
hook up or not hook up
yeah is it a real friendship because i
haven't slept with any of my friends so
that's what i always like
people people use the word friend
loosely
yeah if you know she's got maybe a
history of being a bit of a hoe it is a
bit of a reference a bit of a red flag i
feel like it depends on the girl as well
if it's her lifestyle that that's just
how her life's evolved that she's around
guys more than girls yeah
that's not her fault yeah i've grown up
i've told you guys already i have loads
of brothers so i just grew up around
guys so i just used to hang out with a
lot of guys when i was younger but there
used to be some girls that like there's
there's there's a difference there's
some girls that literally just come
around guys for male attention and then
there's girls that actually
like hanging out guys because they have
interests with guys like same interests
like
like sports and stuff like that yeah
in
2022 do you think it's harder to find a
relationship or maintain one
maintain
and why
just because of how modern society is
yeah yeah it's like society's just like
to you have fun while you're young
and stuff and there's just have fun
while you're young but you also got to
try and get your career sorted
you have kids by the time you're like
30. yeah because like i don't be having
kids at 40 45 because when they turn 18
and stuff and go drinking i don't want
to be 60 taking my yeah
i want to go partying with
that's the one thing like in the
manosphere the sector of youtube they
really push guys to get married later um
which i could see like maybe waiting
until you're like built up and like
established a little bit but i'm like
i see my dad with my youngest sister
like he's in his 50s my sister is like
15
and it's just like hard for him to like
keep up
so why else do you think it's harder to
maintain a relationship than to find one
there's just so many
there's just so many like outside
factors
nowadays i feel like back in the days
you didn't have social media you didn't
have youtube you didn't have any of
these like other outlets it was just
them and the people that you talked to
and that's it and so it was easier to
not have the pressure of
this person saying this and
social media and projecting all this
stuff on a relationship
and people saying or just people putting
their input in
and i think that's why it's harder to
maintain it because there's so many
outside factors and there's so many
new options you can see like ooh i like
that i like what that person has do you
think social media has kind of
negatively affected it yeah
yeah
i feel like um nowadays people try to
find a problem in the relationship
instead of
like social media is like this is a red
flag that's a red flag that's a red flag
and then some people make that their
personality trait yeah oh that's a red
flag maybe i shouldn't go there yeah but
sometimes you just like obviously
there's certain stuff that you shouldn't
do that shouldn't allow but
like not everyone in this world is
perfect and you kind of have to
compromise but this society doesn't
really
like look at compromising and stuff like
that i feel like it's kind of fear-based
a little bit like everyone's so afraid
of getting hurt they almost like shoot
themselves in the foot in the process
because ever like
everyone has red flags yeah i have a
youtube channel i can't imagine that's
gotta be original
i was like
i feel like with like culture nowadays
and i've i haven't experienced this
personally but i've seen it in um
my brother's relationship where
um
[Music]
he
he was with this girl and it's now they
have a kid together and he's been
in my eyes the best for
just our situation he's been the best he
could be been there taking care of him
all this that in the third
and
it's like in the culture nowadays
if you have a good guy
it's you have to find something wrong
with him because that's how culture
perceives it like oh no
he ain't no good he a bad baby father
blah blah blah it's just like when you
do have something good in front of you
it's like you try to find something try
to look for something try to find
something best so you can be like ha i
knew it instead of just
accepting like this person is like a
good person i don't have to find
anything bad with them like i don't have
to be like what i see on tv just to be
able to go to my girls or my guys and be
like you know what this person did edit
it out and tell them that right i think
that's one thing
well i feel like like social media says
to women never settle yeah like they're
like what you don't think some guys
settle for you
the thing is yet it's like for me i'm
just like there's so many there's like
so many ten tens out there
like he could go he could i'm not saying
he could but he could be with anyone who
are you not calling yourself a den no
but i'm just saying that there's always
there's always someone prettier and yeah
there's someone that's probably better
than me or a better girlfriend than me
but i feel like um
because of that fear we have in our head
like he he might go for this girl might
go for that girl like we start to create
problems in our relationships yeah
yeah
you also
you think
i just feel like
like
i would never call myself a ted i don't
understand what girls like i don't know
like close to ten i'd be a victoria's
secret model
i don't know i don't have the results to
show like what makes what makes a person
a 10 is it just looks
i think beauty is in the eye of the
beholder because like one i could find
someone like a 10 10 you could find
zero you know yeah it just depends on
the person i don't think like there's a
specific like i know there's society has
like a certain type of beauty standard
but i don't think that's that's like
everyone's beauty standard i just think
um scarlett johansson is more attractive
than amy schumer
okay i'm gonna just research
scarlett johansson
oh amy
amy you know who amy schumer is i'll
show you you know what i'm really bad
with names
she's a comedian
oh okay as soon as she said like i just
feel like there's some like
i mean there's some like everyone has a
type that maybe goes down one or two but
like
i just feel like there's some
okay yeah
but
okay um super chat super chat hookup
culture helps destroy marriage yes or no
i'd say yes what do you say
yes i feel like
so if you're always hooking up with
people and you're having
sex with this person sex with that
person that's with that person and then
you kind of like maybe you've had like
sex with like one person that's really
really good and then you find someone
they eventually later down the line that
you're really attracted to
like you vibe and everything but that
sex is not the same as that one person
well because you compare it yeah yeah
but if you have nothing to come yeah i i
agree
yeah i would say that um it does
destroy marriages but that like the only
thing because you could you could be um
you could be a virgin
but
in
your whole life or not whole line but in
your like throughout your life you've
been watching
things online i don't know if i can say
that word yeah okay you've been watching
porn and you have this perception of
how it should be and then you get to and
you're like this isn't it like well but
you don't think that's part of hookup
culture say corn
oh corn yeah
i think that's like i think that's part
of it like hookers
um
i would say okay if we're
if it's a broader category than just
hooking up i would say that's a part of
yeah
but you don't think so
no if
if you are marrying someone you've
forgotten about all the hookups you've
had i'd say
you're just gonna magically erase
although it's not actually a raise but
there's a reason you're marrying someone
so
those other hookups i forgot yeah but
what if what if you love your wife and
it's good sex but you still remember
that great sex you had like with that
one girl like 10 years ago that like was
mine she was a wifey material but yeah
she wasn't she wasn't you could never
destroy a marriage
like i don't know i just think
now don't get married you're obviously
satisfied with the sex you're getting
i
think women would beg to differ
on that and women need to talk
so you could talk to that guy
so you said if you want to be satisfied
speak up
that is true
i i agree i don't i think a lot i think
a lot of girls don't but i just
i i think there's
afraid to hurt guys feeling sometimes
yeah
because you know i saw this video about
your cheat on a guy
no
no
that doesn't hurt his feelings
not me
yo
that that's a fact that's true i'm not
saying me but that's true like girls do
like yeah i wonder why that is like we
we won't communicate
and our women won't communicate in one
area but
they'll go off and do something like oh
i'll just go find it my own way when you
can just talk just talking yeah
experimenting and changing things up
you'll just
disappear and break his heart yeah i'm
gonna go get it from someone else that's
that's very
so they say that the girl married well
it's because the girl wants the family
and uh so like they call that the beta
she marries the beta and cheats with the
alpha
because that's the guy she when she
wants kids and she wants a guy to stick
around for the kids so she has kids and
cheats with alpha and he's a symphony
he's found the wrong girl
yeah but he doesn't know how is a guy
supposed to know
if you know you know yeah
okay um another two dollar super chat
from some viagra that i can help with
mike with minecraft
okay i send them your way
okay i think i'm gonna end the show on
that note
uh i thought today was fun we had a lot
of fun
thank you guys so much for coming um if
you want to go around and tell the
people where they can find you starting
with you jess um on ig it is it's ya
girl underscore jess if you wanna follow
me on tik tok it's the same thing but
there is
six s's and jess so it's like
actually let me see i think it's just
all one word honestly let me turn down
the volume
uh it is oh it's just all together it's
a girl just and there's
a lot of s's in there
and on
youtube it's the same thing
for me follow me on tik tok because i
won't be adding back on instagram
amani underscore xox
for me insta just sam underscore james97
and i'm i haven't done it yet but i'm
gonna put
maybe not your instagram
you're not gonna let them follow you
you're gonna be in that that queue for a
while
okay you can sit in her queue everybody
follow amani okay guys um don't forget
to subscribe to the channel and let me
know in the comments what topic you guys
want us to cover next time
and
um
also guys for real buy the meal plan if
you want to lose weight i swear to god i
swear to god this this [ __ ] works it is
the best meal plan i've ever been on and
i would not be recommending